okay so today's draft is uh cities that
will go craziest
there's two the wildest super bowl
celebration
the wildest super bowl celebration
there's two easy answers here but i'll
go with the one that is near and dear to
my heart
and that is the great city
of buffalo new york and if the buffalo
bills
ever get to the mountaintop you've seen
how crazy those fans are when they stink
when it's 10 degrees out and they're
tailgating a
2 and 14 team
doesn't matter they're still passionate
give me the buffalo bills that city
would be absolutely insane if they could
ever win a super bowl
they had that stretch of getting to four
in a row which
is so impressive and so rare and so
difficult and they won none of them and
then they had that long period of time
where they didn't even get to the
playoffs and now they're relevant again
i agree with you buffalo fans would be
among the most raucous win or lose in
the super bowl they're just they they
love their team and and yes you give
them that reason to celebrate and and it
would be a celebration unlike any other
in cleveland i gotta go cleveland
and and look there's gonna be a lot of
celebrations before the super bowl it
could be they have nothing left by the
time they get to the super bowl because
think about it getting to the playoffs
huge celebration winning a playoff game
gigantic celebration they haven't won a
playoff game since the team came back
into the nfl in 1999 getting to the
super bowl for the first time ever trim
you know i may have to go because really
they will have nothing left they will
have burned it down already by the time
we get to the super bowl and they win
the super bowl because
it's too much for the bills at least
they've been there before the browns
have never been there but still i got to
go with cleveland and and you know back
when the browns were winless and
struggling and you know browns fans get
upset when you point out that they stink
it's like folks i'm trying to demand
better on your behalf i want cleveland
fans to have a team that will be
relevant and competitive and in the mix
for playoff birth you don't have to go
every year but it'd be nice to go once
every five
so i i cleveland would be cleveland
would be over the top but the
celebrations along the way you
accumulate it all the celebrations along
the way plus the super bowl celebration
there'd be nothing like it in the
history of sports
mike if you want cleveland to be good
don't you think you shouldn't be talking
about them in the super bowl that's some
unrealistic expectations you're going to
talk about
one
just stop it
all right next pick my next pick uh
we're sticking with uh we're sticking
with the teams that have uh either never
been to a super bowl never won a super
bowl because i think that's really the
recipe here right like
it's the teams that would have that uh
once in a lifetime party because it's
never actually happened so i'll go with
the detroit lions as my next pick the
city of detroit loves their lions the
lions have been uh arguably the worst
franchise in the last 30 years i mean
the last time they went to the playoffs
was or sorry the last time they went to
the nfc championship game won a playoff
game was 1991 correct is that right
yes that's a long time that's a long
time to just win a playoff game they
haven't done that they 1991 win a
playoff game so i think if they could
ever uh put together a playoff run a
super bowl run it would be incredible
the city of detroit would uh celebrate
that like no other and it's just it's an
again another uh franchise that just has
been down on their luck for a very very
long extended period of time and still
has a fan base that is rabid and uh
fanatical and and just wants to have a
winning football team
they actually had a celebration
four years ago at halftime of a game
commemorating the 25th anniversary of
the last time they won a playoff game
and
i don't think that's something you want
to celebrate the silver anniversary of
it just underscores the dysfunction that
has engulfed that franchise for decades
so i don't think in detroit they would
know what to do with themselves if that
team found a way to the super bowl and
ended up winning it's a lot like what
would happen in cleveland the
celebrations along the way
would exhaust
the ability to have the right kind of
celebration when you win the super bowl
because everything would be a major
surprise for the lions and here's how
long ago it was they won a playoff game
you were six and i'm trying to picture
six-year-old big cat with a mustache did
you have a mustache when you were six
yes i did a full mustache i was a man
uh and i was thinking about you know
super bowls and getting ahead of myself
but yeah this is a good pick by me i'm
dominating this draft and i actually
might i'm gonna say it right now it's
not a friday it's not a friday until you
declare that you're dominating the draft
i have like four picks that i could go
with with my last pick it's crazy how
many picks i have in my brain right now
well we got plenty of time and i have
plenty of ideas as well there's plenty
of fan bases out there that have been
suffering for a very long time and this
one is kind of a corollary to your
buffalo bills pick and this is a team
that that finds a way every once in a
while to get close to getting back
and they get smacked down and it's
always some
some extravagant
ridiculous failure something that you
look back on you don't want to think
about it anymore like gary anderson
missing the field goal in 1998 that
would put him up 10. brett favre with
the crossbody throw when they're in
position to kick a field goal and beat
the saints it's always something it's
always something that keeps the vikings
from getting back to the super bowl they
were there four times in the 70s it's
been 44 years and counting since they've
been back and there's just that that
there's a greater sense of anticipation
that like this has to happen this has to
happen this has to happen and i think
that would make it all explode if and
when it ever does happen although
i i probably would bet the under
yeah it's probably never going to happen
you're right um
it also be zero degrees in minnesota
which always takes a little bit out of
the uh celebration so i'm gonna go with
a little bit of a warmer city and we had
we talked about it at the beginning of
this hour how about the atlanta falcons
how about a franchise that has been
close a couple times and has been to
that super bowl had 28 to three and i
think when you talked to atlanta sports
fans you know they had that stretch
there where they had georgia in the
national championship up against uh
alabama they fall short they haven't
been able to do it and then the falcons
up 28-3 they fall short they're not able
to do it atlanta also seems like a city
that would have a really fun party if
they could ever get over the finish line
so i'll say the atlanta falcons that
would be an awesome awesome party and
also not really cold
yeah i i don't disagree with that one
although
to the extent you were dominating i
think that your dominance is starting to
wane in these final two rounds i'm gonna
go look
i'm shifting to a team now that actually
has multiple trophies in the case it's
very easy to say well the cities that
have never won one that's the those are
the ones that will go crazy yeah but
there are cities that have a history
of winning at a high level that have
gone a very long time without winning at
a high level and when you consider the
following of the dallas cowboys it is
astounding that they continue to be the
most popular team in america it's been
25 years since they've been to the nfc
championship game that is incredible to
me they are a team that has had so much
of this sense that that well you know
we're good enough and we can get there
and we can make it happen you've got
jerry jones talking every year as if
this is the year they're going to get it
done and it's this constant sense of of
disappointment
if they would get it done i mean you
think about the following they have and
you think about the following they have
in texas if they could ever pull it off
it would be huge it would be like
they've never won one before because it
kind of feels like they've never won one
before
uh too spread out dallas is too spread
out of a city so and wrong pick here's a
pick for you mike i just did a little
cars
people don't have cars
you thought that uh the falcons was like
the third pick there i actually have my
third pick as my fourth pick but i took
you off the trail because if you want to
talk true party there's actually only
one city in america that knows how to
party better than every city in america
and that's new orleans and guess what
the new orleans saints if they can win
another one with drew brees
after the minneapolis miracle
after the egregious uh mispass
interference that then forced us to have
the mike florio pass interference replay
rule in 2019
if they can win one with drew brees and
sean payton that party it's already new
orleans if you've ever partied in new
orleans it's insane i was there when
louis when lsu won uh the national
championship which feels like ten years
ago was four months ago five months ago
that party was insane i can only imagine
if the saints could win another super
bowl that city loves the saints and it
already has the base level of everyone's
drunk already anyway so it would be a
perfect party
how have we gone four rounds in this
draft for you
without you mentioning
one of the cities that would go
absolutely berserk if its team could
somehow duplicate what it did to cap the
season that began the year you were born
the bears because mike
mike
absolutely bonkers
i'm learning from you mike i don't talk
about super bowls
you you go no chicago
absolutely insane
chicago is always a bear city first like
you know
the the city loves loves loves the bears
it would go insane it would be the
greatest party you know you saw the cubs
when they won
it would be double that you know i've
been to the you know blackhawks rallies
they've done all that stuff
the bears winning the super bowl
would be absolutely crazy
i just don't want to get ahead of myself
mike because i learned from the best
it's all about week one
who do the bears even play week one i
don't even know the schedule how do you
not know who the bears play week one how
do you not know who you're chicago
it's possible they play there's a lot of
good games week one there's a lot of
good games week one which has caused me
to believe that that they're going to
end up getting week one in and then
maybe regroup and take a couple of weeks
off and and and paste some weeks on to
the end of the season
we play the lions that's why that's why
it's forgettable because i don't really
like when you do division games like
that week one i kind of like to open up
something else
i thought about drafting the 49ers here
too because there's that i tell you
their fan base is raucous
and they've gone that 25 26 years
without winning one i just think when
you have that tradition of excellence
and you go an extended period of time
you have a whole generation of fans who
haven't been able to experience it
themselves in their mind it's like it
never happened so a lot of fan bases
would they all would celebrate but none
of them should talk about it openly as
we established earlier in the program
all right we're going to take a break
and wrap up this
week this day this season i guess of pro
football talk live before we begin our
three week hiatus we'll be back with
more right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports